let's get into the the first segment
because we got a good segue for this uh
don't forget you know ian's chilling
yeah
we didn't do that did you get paintball
uh airsoft paintball
pellets no no they're not paintball
they're just biodegradable
yeah yeah i want to get paintball
pellets that'd be fun that's so don't
forget to smash that like button
comment subscribe we're live at 8 pm
live and uh lydia's producing i'm over
here in the corner
but let's talk about this first story
because i think this uh
there's a lot of talk about with with
the media and and the chaos and all that
stuff
so we had this story come out i covered
this earlier on my main channel
youtube.comcast
cnn cnn and msnbc fret over post-trump
future but i think one of the most
significant portions of this article is
where they say
that cnn's president jeffrey a zucker is
weighing whether to exit the network
amid some tension with his new boss
jason killer killer is that really it
well it's like kylar but it says killer
killer
jason kira the warner media chief
executive whose background is in tech
not journalism
mr zucker is mulling his options over
the holidays no no hold on
you can't criticize that guy because his
background's intact when jeff zucker
is running a news organization i'm sorry
i'll do air quotes news organization
when his background is in reality tv
spare me your best what was his uh
reality show background the apprentice
oh wow
i didn't know that you know that no what
if this is all just like
one big hoax like like people think
you know like the government the
illuminati what the real conspiracy is
that it's just like
it's all scripted like everything
everything we're like
and you go crazy when i do it so jeff
zucker and trump are sitting in a room
and it's like for the next show it's
gonna be trump as president we're gonna
make so much money
trump's like it's a brilliant idea
you're the best jeff i love you and he
shakes his hand well if you remember
before donald trump the mainstream media
was on its way out
a lot of people weren't taking them
seriously their viewership was going
down
and then out comes this orange glorious
man
that gave him all the attention that
gave him the drama that gave him the wwe
kind of wrestling entertainment that
people were striving for and
and there is an argument to make here
that donald trump
did save the mainstream media because
that's a fact
i'm not even kidding that is a hard fact
all of these companies were collapsing
there were layoffs
every other day like between between
2012 and 2016 were they just no like
2014 to 2016. what were they doing from
2011 to 14.
there was a mix of writing off of the
occupy and uh
and ron paul movements and then they
started to realize that
intersectionality and social justice was
making
people really angry and angry people
share more so they started going
nuts ramping up videos of cops beating
people
writing songs about it and there was
there was one website mike.com
started as libertarian ron paul program
like that was a big influence on mines
what time but then what they started
doing they started uh
you know putting up police brutality
videos and finding that it mixed with
social justice narratives better
and then the website just became a
social justice media company
then we started seeing there was
something called like ad
was it called like ad rights traffic
distribution or whatever
where these companies would be like we
get a million views
we'll sell the rights to those views to
you to run ads on our content
and then companies like vice would claim
they were getting you know 100 million
views because they were actually buying
the rights to other content
so it was this big kind of i wouldn't
call it fraud or a scam or anything like
that
but like when you go to someone and
claim spamish
imagine if i claimed my youtube channel
like so you go to socialblade you can
see how many views my channels get my
you know it's like i think right now
i've reduced the amount of content i've
been producing a little bit so it's like
60 70 million or whatever maybe maybe a
little bit
i think it's around per month i think
it's like 75 million it was at 100 a few
months ago way bigger with the election
but i've pulled some of the con
you know i've done a little bit less
content imagine if i like
went to a thousand channels that made
videos of people drinking bottled water
and nothing else
and i said sign the rights to your
viewership to me
and then i found another 25 million
views that were worthless
that make no money and then i started
telling everybody i get 100 million my
network has
exactly that's what they were doing so
at some point before trump
everything started falling apart they
started laying people off you know
shane smith the ceo of vice was like
there's going to be a bloodbath in
digital media
and we saw evaluations tanking then
along comes trump
and then all of a sudden these media
outlets realized if we say the orange
man is bad
people click that button wow yeah and
you brought up a very important point
because there was
even psychological studies that pointed
about how if you make someone emotional
if you make someone angry if you make
them feel a very
strong negative emotion that leads to
more
sharing of articles sharing of links
sharing of news stories
and i remember watching a documentary
about this new kind of
online internet news business and seeing
people in the newsroom
with just uh you know graphics about how
many shares their articles get and it
would be
that's out of the ten most shared
articles per day yeah and it was right
in front of everyone and they were
always trying to beat each other
who would get the most clicks who would
have the most outrageous headlines who
would get the most
potential and when you have a system
like that we have to understand that's
going to have some significant
consequences for the general public you
want
let me tell you guys a story when i was
down in ferguson when the riots were
breaking out
and there's cops you know lobbing you
know i was there gas and everything
i did one of the biggest streams ever
it's really funny to think about because
we get more viewers on this show now
then i would get like
mobile streaming on the street but so
when i was like
one night that i get on my entire
youtube channel in a year when i was in
a lifetime in 10 years
when i was streaming in ferguson and we
uh so my live stream had like we had it
was it was it was being displayed in
three different
pages for a total of like 70 000
concurrent viewers at the height of
these riots
when all was said and done and the riots
lit up and the buildings were like a
whole city block west florissant was
engulfed in flames you drive down the
street you could feel the heat
in your car from how big the flames were
viewership was insane it was
massive out there were bullets flying
i'm hitting the ground the cops are like
run run run there's tear gas everywhere
and you know what when everything
wrapped up and i got on the phone with
the people back in the vice newsroom
you know the one i would say the first
thing they told me was
bro you just broke the record for
concurrence the first time a sub channel
surpassed the parent channel brown i'm
like yes
that was it they were like we can't
believe it because
vice news was not vice it was just like
a sub chat chatter but
we got more concurrence dude yeah they
weren't like
it's a sad day man i can't believe these
buildings are you all right yeah yeah
i was going to say are you okay did you
get shot
but listen listen we're all vultures
right we're all vultures so so did was i
gonna was i gonna be like how dare you
say that to me you should be asking if
no i was like wow awesome i can't
believe how well we did
yeah and that is kind of a sociopathic
mentality especially with everything
that was
that was happening in ferguson and there
used to be
this kind of slogan in news if it bleeds
at least used to be
now i think the slogan is let's butcher
the style cut everyone open up
in the nastiest the most disgusting way
and then we have ourselves the title
it used to be if it bleeds it leads yeah
now it's if it bleeds orange
it leads orange man for now but that
orange sweet elixir
is coming to an end and when it comes to
an end
there's going to be a big reckoning and
we're going to see a lot of these media
companies delicious
each other up it's going to be
disgusting there's going to be a lot of
fired
starbucks drinking flip-flop wearing
yuppies in the city that won't have a
job anymore
and it's good there's going to be a huge
economic reckoning especially with
i think a digital marketing media
collapse which
how can you say is not coming when their
evil villain
is leaving and they won't have anyone
else let's talk about the serious
ramifications of what the media has
become
i'll put it this way i'd like you to
imagine donald trump walking down the
street with a smile on his face waving
to people
and there's a bunch of rats chasing him
nibbling at his at his coattails and his
shoes
and he's constantly like kicking them
away that's what the media has become
the wall street journal writes what
before an op-ed in the wall street
journal says what will we do without
trump
a reckoning for resistance media but
they make a very very important point
they're not just saying oh no without
trump what are we right about
they're pointing out that eric swalwell
was caught banging a chinese spy
and the new york times has not covered
it good point you'd think
a a someone who sits on the uh
intelligence oversight committee in
congress
who was sleeping with a chinese spy
would be front page
news but it's not you know why because
passively in a meeting one source says
donald trump entertained the idea of not
leaving the white house though the idea
was quickly shot down and trump agreed
it was a bad idea
boom headline yeah nothing so that today
i'm reading the news
and it's like trump refuses to leave the
white house
and i'm like wow i wonder what the
source is for this and it was a passive
little sentence in the bottom of a cnn
article
but someone saw it and they were like
trump even suggested what you know
asked his aides what if he didn't leave
the white house and the idea was quickly
shot down and trump agreed
but someone sees that they blow it up
into this big headline trump refusing to
leave the white house and i'm like
i saw the headline and i didn't even
want to read the article because i'm
like oh it has trump in it that means
there's most likely some disinformation
a bull crap
on it with someone just making something
up just to get their headlines just to
get their clicks
and it's so disingenuous but it also is
so hurtful for the political discourse
that is happening in this country
that has been bastardized that has been
destroyed
that has been savaged by these brutes
who only want clicks fame attention and
ad revenue
that has essentially destroyed any kind
of
understanding of media and we're living
in this bizarre world
where there's going to be finally
finally a correction
and they're going to realize holy cow
they're in utter trouble
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you